welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and as our countdown continues to
new nerd stories we can stream safely in
our homes this holiday season
halloween with baby yoda and a christmas
with the ghost of vision future
we do have a bit of time for another
peek under the hood here at new rock
stars and some
very exciting see a year ago in october
2019
we were spider-man homeless trying to
find a new workspace and many of you
generous folks came to our rescue by
becoming patrons of new rockstars
digital studios support
that has honestly saved our asses now
that we are spider-man
work from home thank you so much but
yeah i also get that it can be
weird to be locked in this blue dungeon
with me and having to
look at me especially when you know
let's be honest i clearly do not know
how to dress myself
even before covid i struggled with a
rotation of like six to eight looks that
would
kind of mask my blobbier quarters and
not distract from my roadie scroll
theories but
now these days like i'm sure many of you
i have just surrendered given a [ __ ]
at a fear of entering a hot topic and
now you may have noticed that i just
kind of cycled through the same black
five shirts whose collars have all been
kind of like pinched
downward by this microphone clip this
thing only weighs like
a few grams but like a tiny pebble
diverting a mighty river
father time is snagging his pervy finger
in my flap and stretching it into a deep
v for a gander at my manscaping
i immediately regret that but now
thankfully new rockstars is finally
clothing
the naked after years of demand and for
the first time ever except for when we
accidentally turned on the thing below
the video and i don't know how to turn
it off
we are offering let's do this
whoa look a new shirt folks
not just shirts we got hoodies we got
accessories we got
all kinds of stuff that i will be
wearing in our videos and you can now
get
all to help support this channel maybe
you can get for someone you care about
as a holiday gift
or just treat yourself no one knows your
shirt preferences like you do look we
even got a fancy domain that you can
tickle your keyboard with just go on
over to a new tab and type away
www.newrockstarsmerch.com
this whole merch operation has been one
of the big projects philip has been away
working on for new rockstars that's why
he hasn't been on big question to rogue
theory but he is now here with us to
break down what we are offering welcome
back buddy hi i'm phillip marino you
maybe remember me from such videos as
palpatine and star wars force awakens
all easter eggs and references
full movie just kidding i'm obviously
not the same person that hosted that
video how did i become a completely
different person you ask
easy money spend on clothes that fit me
properly
and also money on muscles to fill out
the clothes with look
seriously we have been approached by a
dozen different companies to set up
merch with and
every single time what do you know we
get a sample and i hate it
all of them when i was chubby they
emphasized my lovely lady lumps and then
when i got swole
from working out not from when i had a
bluetooth in the middle of a rogue
theory episode they made me look
skinnier than
eric boss circa 2006 so i decided to
start my own merch company and thus
epic hero shop was born it's the only
way i could emphasize the quality that i
am obsessed with and also feature
designs that aren't already at every
target and hot topic yeah that's right
we got an in-house team of designers
that have been working non-stop on
crafting these items based on whatever
the internet cares about
right now you won't even have to wait
for hot topic to figure out what the
boys is by the way i think we've now
referenced hot topic three times this
video so where the hell is guy fieri
we are waiting we have merch for you
we tried sending it to flavor town but i
don't think you got it support the
united states postal service so when you
go to nurochstersmerch.com you're gonna
see all kinds of solid neurostars merch
to hide your shame with it's all high
quality nice looking stuff i would
actually wear in real life that has been
my main requirement for this whole merch
thing
yay no more of those stupid shady third
party sellers that mail me
weirdly wrapped scratchy awkwardly
fitting shirts i'm throwing it all out
i've already started
from the waist down look i'm a nerd
philip is a nerd and we know exactly
what nerds are looking for so
finally we're gonna hug you with some of
our nerd love
you probably should have waited to say
that you were bottomless till after the
hug
thing come and get your head speaking of
pouring yourself out here is the best
part of finally doing merch
the more that we can transition to
selling our merch rather than selling
other people's products the fewer
outside sponsors will have to interrupt
our videos with now for
the time being those are the only reason
we still have our jobs but
we would love for new rockstars merch to
be our own in-house small business to
keep us afloat so that
we can become finally more self-reliant
it's exactly like when eric sold
lemonade to emancipate himself from his
birth parents
uh-huh i've been on my own since i was
this many
oh also we almost forgot the thing i am
most excited about this whole
merch thing we are launching a line of
collectible shirts
that are about whatever our latest
obsession of the moment is
it is called latest obsession and guys
when we say collectible remember we're
nerds we know what that means
that means limited run numbered items or
living beings that say their own names
these shirts will only be available for
the length of time that we are making
current breakdowns about that given
topic
and when we run out of our initial
orders we won't be ordering any more it
goes back into the dungeon
with me so our first latest obsession
shirt is to celebrate the return of
boom the mandalorian you're never going
to get lost again because your shirt
will be there to remind you hey
dissed away and that's just shirt number
one and it's available to order right
now but it'll be gone pretty soon before
baby yoda goes through that
rush puberty in the season finale
tearjerker episode of mandalorian season
two
and ooh when you buy this latest
obsession shirt you are gonna get the
option to join us
on screen in the episodes in the form of
a custom shout out
that you can include for just a few
bucks more your words will appear
on screen in the video of our
mandalorian after show episodes
keep it clean there are some yoda
children nearby
again that option is exclusive to those
who get the latest obsession shirt
you could let us know your theory and
how boba fett is going to come back or
maybe how you would personally use the
dark saber or just any kind of message
at all you could
ask your grandma to promo so it begins
you are going to be hearing a lot more
from us about our various offers in the
coming weeks guys we are both
so excited about this and i am
personally excited to start feeling good
about myself on camera
while i am theorizing about plot armor
with a bit of armor of my own
and of course we're really excited to
finally have this way that we can
connect with you all and share the love
while we're talking about stuff we love
thanks as always for watching and for
all your support during this challenging
yet thanks to you
survivable time thank you guys so much
for your support
our jobs are completely dependent on it
say subscribe to rockstars get excited
for the stuff that's coming ahead
thanks again and we'll see you soon this
is the way
[Music]
you